thank you finally starring for news
everybody
there are some elastics dear God someone
has to explain to Jefferson King the
Florida man always Florida arrested for
publicly masturbating in a Burger King
that haven't your way refers to your
food order also if you want to have any
chance at all of acquittal don't take a
mug shot that looks like you're still
masturbating in a burger
neural Native Americans have to concede
that rain dances don't work look the
Southwest has no one loved the way they
were like way to say are you making fun
of Indians no rain dances don't [ __ ]
work paintball my lawn is now made of
dirt I think it's time to admit that the
only time dancing makes vixen rain is
around midnight at the Spearmint Rhino
hero now that the world's shortest man
has passed away after a good life at the
age of 75 it's okay for someone to say
out loud that the Hat wasn't fooling any
exactly new role someone has to tell Kim
Davis's husband who showed up for her
big release event looking like this that
when people already think you are
brainless it doesn't help to dress up
like the Scarecrow
new rule now that Caitlyn Jenner says
she's not offended by the call me
Caitlyn Halloween costume she must share
her plans for the rest of the holiday
season for example will she be going out
on New Year's Eve or staying home and
just watching the ball drop
you
you